today is the last day of this journey  it's been amazing in so many ways but  it's been a struggle especially in  what's happened in the last week  last night Peter told me that his heart  is being pulled in two different  directions and that was like a knife in  my heart Madison left and that's been  really really rough for me but I do  believe things happen for a reason I  don't want to keep giving and giving and  giving and just not feeling like he's  there you could only keep it up for so  long until you're at your absolute  breaking point and that's where I'm at I  know what I have with Hannah Hannah I've  put her through a lot but I just don't  know how I can like continue to power  through this  [Music]